(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre os leilões
judiciais simultâneos do mesmo imóvel.
Isso aí, excepcionalmente, pode acontecer.
Dois juízes diferentes levarem o imóvel ao mesmo
tempo a leilão.
Um dos requisitos de validade do leilão judicial
é a notificação de outros credores com penhoras
averbadas na matrícula do imóvel.
E esse é um dos requisitos que está
lá no nosso checklist, que a gente precisa
verificar antes de participar de um leilão.
A penhora, só recapitulando, é a ordem de
juiz em um processo judicial de cobrança de
algum valor.
As finalidades dessa notificação são as seguintes.
Instaurar o concurso de credores, a gente acabou
de ver na aula anterior que vai ser
instaurado o concurso de credores quando existir mais
de um credor.
Então, em primeiro lugar, essa notificação serve para
avisar para outros credores que aquele imóvel está
indo a leilão e esses outros credores chegarem
naquele processo que está levando o imóvel a
leilão e falar, olha, eu tenho o valor
para receber desse mesmo devedor, tá aqui o
meu valor, tá aqui a ordem judicial que
determinou esse valor.
E a segunda finalidade é justamente evitar que
leilões simultâneos sejam realizados.
Quem faz essa notificação é o leiloeiro.
Então, você consegue levantar com o leiloeiro essa
confirmação, você pode ligar para o leiloeiro, mandar
um e-mail e pedir para que ele
confirme que essas notificações foram feitas ou você
também pode olhar dentro do próprio processo que
está levando o imóvel a leilão.
A gente já sabe aqui que vai ser
necessário analisar o processo que está levando o
imóvel a leilão para saber se os requisitos
foram cumpridos e para avaliar o nosso checklist.
Como o leiloeiro que faz essa notificação dos
outros credores que têm penhoras averbadas, ele vai
mandar essa notificação dentro de cada processo judicial
que determinou essas outras penhoras.
E aí, ele vai apresentar ao juiz que
está determinando o leilão o comprovante dessas notificações
para que o juiz saiba que está tudo
correto.
Então, você consegue sair realmente de duas formas,
ou ligando ou mandando um e-mail para
o leiloeiro ou analisando dentro do próprio processo
porque o leiloeiro vai apresentar isso para o
juiz que levou o imóvel a leilão.
Quando o leiloeiro faz isso, também tem a
finalidade de impedir que leilões simultâneos aconteçam porque
o leiloeiro vai fazer essa notificação dentro de
cada processo que determinou outras penhoras.
Quando ele fizer essa notificação, ele vai peticionar
dentro desse processo informando que realmente outro processo
está levando aquele mesmo imóvel a leilão.
E aí, o juiz desse processo que determinou
essa outra penhora vai tomar ciência de que
está sendo realizado um leilão daquele imóvel em
outro processo.
E ele vai se abster de determinar também
um leilão daquele mesmo imóvel para que não
ocorram leilões simultâneos.
Acontece que, às vezes, de forma muito excepcional,
dois processos caminham ali praticamente no mesmo tempo
e vão chegar à fase de determinação de
um leilão praticamente ali no mesmo tempo.
Então, um juiz vai determinar um leilão e
outro juiz vai determinar outro leilão sobre esse
mesmo imóvel.
Serão leilões simultâneos.
Não deu tempo de um juiz ser notificado
pelo outro da realização daquele leilão e os
dois mandaram o imóvel a leilão.
A finalidade da notificação é exatamente também impedir
que isso aconteça porque isso aí não deveria
acontecer, né?
Dois juízes levando o mesmo imóvel a leilão.
Então, por isso que, às vezes, a gente
encontra o mesmo imóvel indo a leilão judicial
em dois leiloeiros diferentes por ordem de dois
juízes diferentes e, às vezes, até com dois
valores diferentes porque um juiz vai determinar um
percentual de desconto e outro juiz pode determinar
outro percentual de desconto.
Se existirem leilões simultâneos, ficará com o arrematante
que registrar primeiro o imóvel em seu nome.
Então, isso aí não é algo vantajoso porque
a gente participa de um leilão para efetivamente
pagar aquele valor e ficar com o imóvel.
Se, por acaso, forem realizados leilões simultâneos desse
mesmo imóvel, o arrematante que primeiro registrar a
carta em seu nome, ele vai ficar com
o imóvel e o outro arrematante vai ter
que pedir a restituição do seu valor, do
valor que pagou por aquele imóvel que ele
não ficou com aquele imóvel.
Então, isso aí é algo que deve ser
evitado você participar de um leilão desse tipo.
Como você vai evitar isso?
Conferindo o andamento dos outros processos com penhoras
averbadas na matrícula.
E aí você nem precisa olhar o processo
inteiro.
As decisões dos processos, como a gente já
bem sabe, elas são públicas.
A exceção lá é se for um processo
em segredo de justiça.
Então, você vai abrir os outros processos que
têm penhoras na matrícula.
Lembrando que cada penhora vai ter lá o
número do processo.
Então, é só você pesquisar por esse número.
E você vai ver ali quais são os
últimos andamentos públicos daquele processo.
Quais são as últimas decisões.
E só por essas decisões, você já sabe
se aquele processo está chegando ali na fase
de um leilão ou não.
Porque quando for uma fase de leilão, vai
ter uma decisão do juiz, que vai ser
pública, vai estar ali de graça no site
do tribunal para você verificar, nomeando o leiloeiro,
determinando que aquele leiloeiro apresente o edital do
leilão e coisas desse tipo.
Então, se você abrir o andamento e não
tiver lá uma decisão nesse sentido, de nomear
o leiloeiro, de determinar que o imóvel vai
a leilão, de mandar avaliar o imóvel, aí
sim você sabe que aquele processo lá está
longe de determinar um leilão.
E vai dar tempo de você arrematar o
imóvel, fazer todo o trâmite da documentação e
aquele credor lá, realmente ele vai ter que
habilitar o seu crédito no concurso de credores,
não vai dar tempo daquele leilão ser realizado
de forma simultânea.
Isso aí é uma garantia para você.
Então, sempre faça essa verificação para não correr
esse risco de participar de leilão de um
imóvel que pode ser levado simultaneamente a outro
leilão por ordem de outro juiz.